okay let's go uh let's go next where are
we going next it's it's just it's hard
to know
um
because the phone calls are so
widespread let's try going to southcat
southcat you're on the air oh
southcat oh my goodness hello david how
are you oh are you scottish
no australian oh australia oh okay sorry
i misheard your accent initially welcome
thank you so much uh yeah a lot of
people
probably expect me to sound like
crocodile monday with a shrimp on the
barbie but no
um well thanks for taking my call i just
um
i just went to i was having a chat to
somebody
recently
um
about
well he he
his thoughts were that the buildback
better plan um
had an effect on
inflation like
a market of
what from what i believe
quite a bit of an effect on inflation
and i thought
i didn't necessarily agree with that but
uh what are your thoughts if you
no i don't think so inflation uh has
been inflation predates the
infrastructure package passed by joe
biden and it also is global including
you know affecting countries that have
nothing to do with american
infrastructure spending so i've seen no
evidence that that is the case
well thank you for that um
i yeah i appreciate it i hope hopefully
he might be listening um and just
another thing i just want to say i
really appreciate your
the forensic nature in which you comment
on
the
words
the rhetoric that
people in the media
whoever they are over abroad's respect
perspective it's really
important and words matter you know
i appreciate that very much
uh yeah
southcat thank you listen is it is it
like 1 30 in the morning in australia
right now what time is it there it's uh
it's 2 40 i'm uh doing
uh
yeah a bit of work it's the middle of
the night
is it the middle of the night yeah
actually no to 2 40 a.m right yeah a bit
of a night out when i have to get a lot
of work done so
but um oh and one more thing i just just
one quickly um i also appreciate you
mentioning the
situation with healthcare um especially
with
i i saw that i think it's kentucky
have banned abortion yeah i'm not sure
sorry um this is disturbing um i i
really feel
bad about it
so
hopefully uh things will get better yeah
all right southcat you've said it all
thank you so much for the call
thank you david thank you very much keep
up the good work my pleasure thank you
there is southcat from australia the
middle of the night the witching hour as
some uh as some might call it